okay let me say thanks to the final a
new member of the day of 2018
Stephen ern Berg Stephen thank you for
being a david pakman show member also
want to say thanks to Michael Andrews
who is today's longtime sustaining
member of the day with us since March of
2014 going on almost five years Stephen
Michael thank you join them at WWJ in
pakman.com we've got a coupon code this
is twenty twenty still time to get those
new memberships in 2018 and if you want
the biggest membership special of the
year if you want to take advantage of
that it will be happening on January 1
2019 we will be notifying everybody on
our mailing list of this just
unconscionably incredible membership
special you have to get on our mailing
list though by going to david pakman.com
sign up for the newsletter and then
january 1 you will get a very special
personal email from me telling you how
to take advantage of the best membership
special of the year okay I I do sort of
have to thank Donald Trump for something
on this last show of 2018 which is that
we at the David Pakman show
had an incredible 2018 as far as most
metrics are concerned the YouTube
channel has been absolutely on fire we
are now regularly in the sort of 8 to 11
million views per month range on the
YouTube channel in December alone
without counting these sort of last few
days of the month we added net 17,000
subscribers to the YouTube channel
in November we added 15,000 subscribers
to the YouTube channel so thank you
things are looking up for 2019 the
podcast is doing better than ever the
one hour daily podcast that we put out
thanks to everybody who listens on
iTunes stitcher I Heart Radio now on
Spotify and Pandora to new things that
we added during 2018 it has been an
incredible 2018 and I mean listen it's
the truth right I didn't vote for Donald
Trump but he has inspired a degree of
activism
and a level of interest in politics that
we haven't seen for a long time when
President Obama was president there were
many things to criticize but it wasn't
daily crises and daily scandals in the
way that this is and this has really
helped independent media shows like ours
so will we now not be activists for what
we believe is right of course not but
what we will do is we will continue to
use the platform to the extent that we
have it to advocate for the policies and
the issues and the candidates that we
believe are best now one one metric that
did not do so well in 2018 is that we
actually lost a couple of hundred net
members paid members on our website
which is our primary source of revenue
why did that happen
even though the audience continued to
grow the reason is because of the 2017
ad pocalypse and you might say well hold
on David the the 2017 YouTube ad
pocalypse how did that lose you members
in 2018 it doesn't make any sense I'll
explain sort of a peek behind the
curtain as to how a lot of this stuff
works
like most membership systems we have a
sort of natural new subscriber rate and
a natural cancellation rate so on the
one hand people sign up on the other
hand some portion of those people cancel
their memberships as they move on to
doing other things in their life
following other shows whatever or their
credit cards expire their debit card
payments get declined whatever so
there's this kind of natural what's
called a churn rate and ideally as the
show keeps growing if things go right
the new subscriber rate is always bigger
than the unsubscribe rate so your total
number of active members goes up
indefinitely and that's been the case on
the show for something like seven years
in 2017 ad pocalypse happened where we
lost 99 percent of our youtube ad
revenue for a month then we were down
like 50 percent for many subsequent
months and it never really recovered and
thankfully when we told the audience
that that was going on in 2017 it caused
this giant influx of new members way
a higher new-member rate than the sort
of natural subscription rate that a show
our size would expect so 2017 was great
when it comes to new members
unfortunately what this means in 2018 is
that way more people had their one-year
membership anniversaries and a lot more
people than normal had credit and debit
cards that expired or had payments
declined so in 2018 we had a much higher
rate of loss of members without anything
driving new members in 2018 so sadly we
lost several hundred net members in 2018
and if you think about 60 bucks a year
or six bucks a month that adds up to a
pretty significant deficit when it comes
to membership revenues so that is one
thing that did not do well in 2018
that's why we're doing this huge
membership special on January 1 to try
to kick things off as strongly as
possible so if you want to help us chip
away at the damage of 2018 sign up now
at join pakman.com coupon code this is
20/20 saves you 40% but if you want to
help in 2019 January 1 we are going to
be offering the biggest membership
special of the year we we often do this
on the first day of the year just get on
our newsletter sign up for our
newsletter at david pakman.com January 1
you will get an email telling you how to
take advantage of this the other thing
by the way I have to mention we may be
getting rid of the david pakman show
coffee program we have two types of
coffee drip coffee and espresso coffee
available at david pakman.com slash gear
partially because we've had a studio
move in so many other things going on we
have not done as good a job as we should
have a promoting coffee in 2018 and
we've been talking with our roaster if
that program doesn't grow we probably
are gonna need to access so if you
didn't know that we had this available
and you already buy coffee regularly and
you're into buying coffee from us
instead of from somebody else and it's
really good coffee by the way go to
david pakman.com slash gear and take
advantage of that and then if we get an
influx of orders we will keep the coffee
program in 2019 I would love to keep it
but if it's not doing well
overhead and administration of it simply
doesn't make sense
send guests suggestions for the new year
send story suggestions for the new year
it's the last show of 2018 follow me on
instagram at david pakman to see what's
happening behind the scenes in the
studio today